6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth. Women today are having fewer babies. More women are delaying having children
until their 40s. The period of 10 years in life between 40 and 49. And some women are
giving birth in their 50s, their 60s, even their 70s.
There are many reasons behind the trend for older mums, including better access to education
and careers. But there are also health risks to having children later in life. So in this
programme we'll be asking when are you too old to have a baby. And as usual we'll be
learning some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first I have a question for you Neil. In 2019, Mangayama Yaramati gave birth to
twins in the state of Andhra Pradesh, South India. But these were no ordinary twins because
Mangayama was the oldest recorded woman ever to give birth. So how old was the oldest
ever mum when she gave birth? Was she a 53 years old, b 63 years old or c 73 years old?
I'm going to guess 63.
Okay Neil, we'll find out the correct answer at the end of the programme.
Professor of Reproductive Science at University College London, Joyce Harper, has been studying
the trend of women choosing to have babies later in life. Here she shares her discoveries
with BBC World Service programme Global Story.
Twenty thirty years ago women were having children at a much younger age. Now it's become
quite normal for women in their 30s. As we see with the world data, there's many countries
where women have their first birth over the age of 30. But this is quite a new phenomena.
That's why this term geriatric mother unfortunately still lingers.
Professor Harper uses the word phenomena to describe the trend for older mothers. Phenomena
are unusual or significant facts and events that exist and are talked about. People often
get this wrong, but the plural form is phenomena and the singular is phenomenon.
The concept of older mothers is still quite a new phenomenon and attitudes towards them
are changing.
Mothers over the age of 35 used to be called geriatric, a word many found offensive. Fortunately
this term is no longer used, but social disapproval of older mothers still lingers. If something
lingers it continues to exist longer than usual or expected.
Yes, in some cultures older mothers are still disapproved of. But wait a minute Neil,
it takes two to make a baby. What's the man's role in all of this?
Well unlike women whose ability to naturally get pregnant declines sharply in their 40s
men's fertility last longer. Rolling Stone singer Mick Jagger famously had his eighth child
with his 29 year old partner at the age of 73. So are older fathers more socially acceptable
than older mothers? Yes, things Professor Harper, as she explained to BBC World Services
global story. We do have a bit of agenda problem it because if this was a man in his 60s,
70s and even 80s and he's father to child, most people would pass him on the back. But
they're probably patting him on the back because he's absolutely got so much younger partner.
But if we've got a woman in her 60s, 70s or got a bit 80s having a child, then it does
have a sort of shock reaction and makes people feel uncomfortable.
Professor Harper thinks that society is more accepting of older fathers than older mothers.
A 70 year old man can still father a child. He can make a woman pregnant who then gives birth.
And most people would pat him on the back. An idiom meaning give someone praise or congratulations.
On the other hand says Professor Harper, God forbid a woman having a baby in her 80s.
Here the phrase God forbid is used as a way of saying you hope something will not happen.
There's another side to this story though. In the West, young women from Gen Z, the generation
born since the year 2000, are saying they won't have children at all.
In more traditional countries meanwhile, a woman's role is as a mother and many pray to God
to be blessed with a child. Which is exactly what happens to Mangayama Yaramati, the
South Indian woman I asked you about in my question, Neil. In 2019, she became the oldest
recorded woman ever to give birth. Right and I guessed she was 63 years old at the time.
Which was the wrong answer I'm afraid. In fact, she was even older, 73. Okay, let's recap
the vocabulary we've learnt in this programme starting with the phrase in your 40s. Which
describes the period of 10 years in someone's life when they're aged between 40 and 49.
Phenomena describes any significant facts or events that we know exist and can be observed
and discussed. If something lingers, it continues to exist longer than usual or expected.
The verb to father means to make a woman pregnant who then gives birth to a child.
The idiom Pat someone on the back is used to describe giving someone praise, congratulations
or encouragement. And finally, the expression God forbid is a way of saying that you hope
something will not happen. Once again, our six minutes are up but don't forget to join
us again soon for more trending topics and useful vocabulary here at 6 Minute English.
Goodbye for now. Bye.